اطباء وطب العام يتظاهرون بالمئات في
شوارع باريس تنديدا باوضاعهم البذريه
ويتهمون سلطه لاشراف بالاستخفاف بمطالبهم
الملحه تشير لافتاتهم الى ان الهدف من
الاضراب والتظاهر ليس المطالب الماديه
وحسب للتنبيه لعواقب وضع مهني بات ينظر
بانهيار النظام الصحي الفرنسي برمته
مفعول الصدمه
التشغليه لدى الاطباء الشباب ونطلب من
الدوله التوفير الاعتمادات اللازمه
لتمكيننا من مواصله تقديم خدمات ذات جوده
ورعايه افضل للمواطنين فرنسا
مساعده الاطباء متفقم وتعتقد بسداد
امكانيه تعويض الاطباء باجراء الفحوص عن
بعد بتقنيات التواصل الحديثه من غير
المعقول ان تتجاهل الحكومه واهميه الطب
العام لانه في غياب شبكه عيادات طب عام من
قويه ستنهار المستشفيات العامه لانها
ببساطه ستعجز عن استيعاب جميع المرضى وفي
خضم الاضراب يشتد الضغط على العيادات التي
اثرت الاستمرار في تقديمتها
الانتظار لمده تتراوح بين 53 ساعات
مريض يوميا طيله الايام الماضيه ولم تتمكن
من الاستجابه لضعف هذا العدد من الباحثين
عن موعد مع الطبيب
اضافيه في فتره نعاني فيها اصلا من كثافه
الاعباء المهنيه
الحكومه الفرنسيه عارضت عن تفهمها لمطالب
الاطباء لانها اعتبرت ان شنا الاضرابي في
وقت تواجه فيه المستشفيات الفرنسيه
والضغطا كبيرا امر غير مسؤول معلنه انها
ستقدم لاحقا خريطه طريق لتلبيه تطلعات
العاملين في القطاع الصحي يبدو ان هذا
الاضراب
ادراك النقابيا الاخير الذي يشهده قطاعه
صحه الفرنسي في مستهل العام الجديد حيث
لوحه النقابات بتوسيع دائره المضربين
لتشمل القطاع الصحيه العامه وهددت بخوض
اضراب مفتوح اعتبارا من العاشر من الشهر
الجاري لطفي المسعودي الجزيره باريس